now republican senator josh hawley
tonight is raising serious concerns
about the record of biden's supreme
court nominee judge katanji brown
jackson now pointing to what he calls an
alarming pattern of lenient treatment
towards sex offenders for example as
hawley writes quote as a member of the
u.s sentencing commission judge jackson
advocated for drastic change in how the
law treats sex offenders by eliminating
the existing mandatory minimum sentences
for child pornography and citing one
case where the sentencing guidelines
call for a sentence of up to 10 years in
prison but judge jackson sentenced the
perpetrator to only three months behind
bars now white house press secretary jen
i like to lie sake said that the
criticism was taken out of context and
some of the remarks were something a
witness said in order to ask a question
and that's not all because we're also
learning that biden's nominee praised
the discredited 16-19 project in an mlk
day speech back in 2020 the confirmation
hearings they are expected to begin on
monday here to explain more missouri
republican senator josh hawley senator
tell everybody what you found
well what i found sean is a pattern here
of treating sex offenders leniently
those who have gone after children and i
think we just have a basic question to
ask are we going to get a judge here
who's going to protect children or who's
going to protect child predators it's a
simple question it's one i think that
every parent in america would like
answered but it's one that the white
house doesn't want to answer and so far
judge jackson doesn't want to answer it
total radio silence from her and if you
look at her record what you see is this
is someone who has consistently let sex
predators child sex predators off the
hook for people who have been convicted
of child porn offenses she's
consistently given them lenient
sentences slaps on the wrist this is
someone who has raised the question
whether sex offender registries are
unconstitutional
whether notifying parents when there's a
sex offender in the area is
unconstitutional she suggested all of
that i mean this is very troubling we
need to get the answers
you say that this came both as a judge
and a policy maker meaning her
background and you're concerned that
this is a record that will endanger
children and you cite other cases i mean
how does somebody facing a 10-year
sentence for something this serious only
get three months in prison
yeah that's the problem sean if you look
at what she's done as a judge on the
bench when she had the chance to put
away child predators over and over again
when it comes to these child porn cases
these are pedophiles we're talking about
she chose to give them the lightest
sentence possible in case after case i
mean you mentioned one the guidelines
recommended 10 years she gave him three
months and we could go on and on the
problem is i haven't been able to find a
single case where she has had a child
porn offender a pedophile in front of
her where she hasn't given him the most
lenient sentence she possibly could and
again this is someone since law school
who has been saying that the sex
offender registries may be
unconstitutional that notifying parents
about sex offenders in their
neighborhood may be unconstitutional and
who voted as a member of the u.s
sentencing commission she voted to get
rid of the mandatory minimum sentences
for child porn so this is a this is a
long pattern it stretches over many
years and we need to get answers on this
you know senator when you look at for
example and you read about prisons and
uh two things that consistently
prisoners don't like that i hear about
one they don't like rats people that
tell on other people to cut deals to
make their life easier and the second
thing is those that are predators
against children uh i can't think of a
single logical reason why there's
leniency on this
this issue considering we're talking
about the most innocent people in
society
have you come to any conclusion as to
why this is
i i can't figure it out sean and this is
what we need to hear from her on i mean
she's really going to have to tell us
this is why her hearings are so
important i mean we need to know why did
she give these offenders such light
sentences why did she vote to get rid of
mandatory minimum sentences the existing
ones anyway for child pornography why
did she say way back as early as law
school why was she saying that maybe
these these sex offender registries and
other protective measures were
unconstitutional i mean these are
questions that she's going to need to
answer and i think every parent in
america is going to want to know the
answers because this is a lifetime
appointment to the u.s supreme court
we're talking about here she could be
ruling on these cases and we need to
know
well we need to know of you real quick
of your fellow republicans do they share
your concern okay we got 10 seconds you
know i i hope so sean i hope so and i
think i think you're going to see a lot
of tough questioning next week